Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello everybody.
Welcome.
Hello.
I've just been vibing to the opening.
It's so relaxing.
Yeah.
And it's over.
Anyway, welcome you guys to Rude Factory.
Guardians of Azuma.
This one seems kind of... dramatic.
I think.
I was watching the trailer.
And... actually, I also have to confess.
This is my first ever Rune Factory game.
So... I don't know.
I want to farm and I want to romance.
But... if I romance... do I have to pick a guy character?
Is that how it works?
Rune Factory.
Give us the ladies.
I don't have to?
I don't... I don't need to?
Oh man.
Well... what did you do?
What did you...
Like you're a little vote for the...
Super, what are... what are you... what are you apologizing for?
What do you...
what are you apologizing for?
You can romance any gender.
Yeah.
Let's go.
I really wanted to be the girl.
She's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
We're gonna be the girl and we're gonna get with Iroha.
Iroha.
I was like... wait a second.
I was... So, this is a sponsored stream.
Thank you so much MarvelousUSA for sponsoring me for this stream.
If you're interested in the game, I have a pinned link.
And I also have a link in the description.
But, um... I'm excited.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh... Uh... I'm still also very jet-lagged.
So... I'm still very jet-lagged.
So... I will do my best.
Um... The game is for... PC.
And Switch.
And also... Switch 2.
So, if you've got your new old... New... I almost said new old Switch.
That's like an oxymoron.
If you've got... If you've got... A new... New Switch 2.
You can play it there.
Whoa... And, um... Yeah... PC 2?
No... No... Only PC 1.
Switch to what?
But yeah... If you... Don't have a new Switch... You can... Play on a regular... Original Switch.
And... Also... The game... Is in... Nihongo... Or... Eigo.
That's... English... Translators... No...
And... But we'll be playing in English today.
So that I don't have to... Narrate.
So that I can rest my voice a little bit.
Eigo... Leggo... Leggo... My Eigo.
Wow... You're so cultured.
Arigato.
But also... I noticed that... With the other Rune Factory games... They're very... How do I say... Uh... Oh my gosh...
Thank you guys for the Super Chats... Ah...
Uh...
I can't really do... Uh... Birthday... Messages... Today... Because it is like... A... You know... A sponsored stream... But... Uh... Happy Birthday...
Uh... Uh... Adam... Skunk... It's a great name... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... Thank you... Thank you so much for the... Uh... Um... But... What was I saying... Oh gosh... I lost my train of thought... Uh... Uh... Oh... Um... The other... Rune Factory games... I noticed were very like... Like... Western Fantasy... You know... It's like... Knights and... Ladies... But this one is very...
Uh... Uh... Japan... Inspired... So... You can... Unleash your... Weeabu Soul... Hahaha... Yeah... We're... We're... Japanese... Inspired this time... And... I think there's dragons... Not... I think... I know there's dragons... Hmm... Hmm... So let's just get started... New game... They gave me the... The DLC too... Hahaha...
And one of them... Was just... Swimsuit DLC... So I hope I get to see that... Hahaha... I hope... Okay... Show me what you look like... Wait... See... Isn't there... I mean... They're both cute... But like... She's so pretty...
I like how... They have very similar bangs... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... She's very cute... Wait... Can I like... Spin her around?
No... Haha... Show me... Show me what you got in the back... Pretty lady... They look nice... Right?
Well... We'll go with the girl... She said... Hmm... Good choice... Oh my gosh... Wait... I can put my own name...
Vito... I like both to be aged... Yeah... They're both great... Confirm... A fine name... When were you born?
Spring?
Wait... Oh... 7th... Like... 7th... Uh... Wait... Autumn 7th?
Wait... What?
Winter 7th?
Huh?
Hahaha... Oh... It's because...
I'm on the 7th... Hahaha... Hahaha... Hahaha... I was like... Oh... That must be... July... Hahaha... Hahaha... There are only 4 months... Well... October... October is technically autumn... Even though it's early... October... So October 1st... Autumn 1st... Baby... Hahaha... Hahaha... So I see... Then how much of a challenge...
What do you desire?
Story... Focus on the plot... While fighting... Easier battles... Balance... The intended experience... Hard... Test your mettle... Against... Stronger enemies... We'll go with balance... It's my first time playing... Minto... It's a holiday... Interesting... No... No hard... No hard... No hard... No... Hahaha... Holiday is just short for weekend... Oh... I guess that makes sense... Huh?
Yes...
She's like... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... Hmm... Oooh... She's so pretty... Oh my god... She's got lippy... Cute... Oh!
Our dragon... Hahaha...
The two dragons... Why do you stand in my way?
Me?
I could ask you the very same... She sounds familiar... Enough talk!
Why are we fighting?
I don't think these dragons have arms.
Oh, this they do.
I just saw it.
I thought they were just like snakes.
Worm dragons.
Yeah, they're just little worms.
Oh, sorry.
My cursor is like right in the center.
Yeah, kick his butt.
He's got big teeth and she's got little tiny teeth.
I always notice teeth first.
Am I the only one like that?
Do you guys notice teeth?
Oh, good morning, princess.
Oh, princess.
Minto!
It's me!
Just a dream.
Oh, wow.
It's really fully voiced.
Oh, thank goodness for me.
It's me!
Good morning!
Finally awake in there?
Who is it?
I hear a cute girl.
Oh, the adventure log.
Oh, look.
They're actually Nakayoshi.
They're actually friends.
If you feel lost, use escape to open the cam menu and check the tutorials in your adventure log.
Which may offer some helpful hints.
Took you long enough, sleepyhead.
Do you have any idea what time it is?
Nope.
Oh, did I do there?
Oopsie.
I'll move with the waster.
Oh, I completed the tutorial.
I can attack.
Pretty.
When she swipes the petals.
Oh, what's in here?
My wardrobe.
You can change it to any...
Wait, do I have the swimsuit?
Ooh!
Thank you, Marvelous staff, for providing me with the DLC.
Wait, I can rotate.
Ooh!
It's actually quite modest.
It's so cute.
It's so cute!
Here, I was thinking we're gonna get, like, some Senran Kagura...
Anyway.
Confirm.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, we're good.
So, yeah.
I just started the game.
I just start...
Wait, that's my girl!
You see her out the door?
I'm gonna romance you!
You...
You know how...
She a pain...
She...
Appeals to all my...
Particulars.
She's really cute.
I'm sorry.
Oh, God!
Look at her face!
She's so cute!
Now, hurry and wash up.
We'll have breakfast after we tidy the shrine.
Yeah.
More cleaning today?
I didn't realize you were such a neat freak.
Not Minto calling someone else a freak.
Talk about the pot calling the kettle black.
Cleanliness is a daily routine.
Besides, those who don't work, don't eat.
Oh, wow.
I guess that's true.
I suppose.
Not her being in the bikini.
Oh...
I don't know if I can take her seriously.
Can I ask you to take care of the sweeping again?
Oh, I have to...
Okay.
I guess the...
That's not the maid's duties.
It's...
Green maid, sign me up!
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, minigame?
Oh, she's also sweeping.
You got this, honey!
Yep.
Keep...
Keep sweeping them circles.
Oh no.
Do I have hiccups?
You're saying...
Wait.
You're saying her name is pronounced Iroha, not Iroha.
Oh?
Sweep.
Oh...
Oh, we got some grass.
Sweep.
Got some weeds.
We got a rock!
Sweep.
We got some more grass.
You never know what you're gonna find in there.
I've had to believe you've been in this for half a year now.
You never know what you're gonna find in the pile of leaves.
Has it really been that long?
She still doesn't know how to put on clothes.
And boy, did we start off with a bang.
I'll never forget walking into the shrine...
Wait, it's been half a year?
And you just left the roof?
You just left the roof like that?
What?
Wait...
You mean you haven't fixed the roof in half a year?
Rain!
And...
Oh my god, it's probably...
She's too short.
She can't reach the ceiling.
So true.
It's fine, yeah.
I can't help but think you must be someone really special.
Say my name, Iroha.
Minto.
That roof repair is expensive.
We gotta go to the shrine more and donate more, you guys.
Like a messenger from the Dragon God or something.
Oh, well...
They like having an indoor pond.
Oh please, I doubt that.
Divine Envoy or No, I'm happy to have you.
Since so many villagers have moved out, it feels good welcoming a new neighbor for a change.
Why is she so smug?
Oh, she's so cute though.
Oh, I like Iroha.
Thank you.
I'm glad to hear it.
Alright, we did our chores.
Let's walk around a little bit before we talk to Iroha some more.
Ooh.
Come on, be serious.
Oh, sorry.
I got scolded for exploring.
I got...
I'm ready to go on adventures.
Oh!
Oh yeah.
We climbing.
Do you think we share the bed or...
Wait, so we really did just leave it like this.
Oh wait, inspect.
It's awfully drafty in here.
Most likely because of that enormous hole in the roof.
So
not even they like it.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
There.
Perfect.
And I'm sure the god residing here would agree.
Mm-hmm.
So, who is the god of the shrine anyway?
Uh, good question.
All I know is that they're a dragon.
Oh.
What was their name again?
You don't even know?
I think it's...
Moko something?
Moko something.
Oh, that's kind of cute.
Yeah.
Anyway, they're a protector god.
So we should pay our respects.
I'm gonna turn auto on.
Oh.
There we go.
Could you use this to perform the ritual prayer and dance?
Mokoku?
Oh.
Use dance of bonds at the save statue.
We equip it.
Oh.
Okay.
I got it.
I do it at a statue or I just...
Prosper.
Oh.
Oh, neat.
What did that do?
Prosper.
Oh.
I offer these humble words.
I think you should have gotten dressed.
Great god of the dragon shrine.
Moko something.
May your divine glory shine forth and bless us all forevermore.
She's got moves.
She was so impressed.
Oh.
Everybody bowed.
Bonding with save statues.
Perform the dance of bonds at a save statue to establish a link with a divine dragon within.
Saving all your progress.
Okay.
So did it save or...
What should I do?
Save.
I'll save anyway.
Cool.
Hiroha, I did it.
Are you so impressed?
Do nothing.
Why a plum branch, I wonder?
I wonder if we had chosen the guy what his bathing suit looked like.
Can it really do that?
Fancy.
Oh.
Suzu.
Suzu cute.
Pull.
I brought you lunch.
The cutest family ever.
Aw, you sweetie.
You're so cute.
And here you go.
Enjoy.
Oh, what did I get?
Thank you so much.
I got leaves.
They gathered...
They gave me all the leaves that I swept up.
Is she hungry too?
They gave to me for...
All the leaves I swept up, they wrapped it up and gave it to me.
Wait, I can give her half or I can eat it?
I'll just eat it when she's not watching.
That's so mean.
I feel like our relationship will go up if I give half to her sister, but...
I kind of want to see the reaction for the second one.
Okay.
Have you eaten already, Iroha?
Yep.
She looks hungry.
She looks so...
Whoa, deep voice.
Grandpa.
Good morning.
Suzu.
I see you're a bright little ball of energy as always.
There's a good girl.
I'm the best girl.
Heck yeah.
She's the best girl.
Would you two come with me?
The IA will be leaving shortly.
And I thought you might like to see her off.
Yeah.
Oh.
Um.
Okay.
My thanks.
You're well.
You're...
My welx.
Right this way then.
Okay.
The swimsuit sticks out so much.
I think we need to change.
I should have said that we had chores to do and get dressed.
Spring Village.
Oh, but it's like so dry.
It looks so dead.
Have you managed to settle in?
Yes.
Everyone's been so helpful.
Good.
Nearly 50 years have passed since the Celestial Collapse.
Oh.
Our village once bustled with travelers from all over Azuma.
Now...
Oh, so they know.
Oh, they did mention that people were like...
...leaving...
...the village.
Ever since that disaster...
...plants and animals alike...
...have lost their figure.
You can make everyone wear a swimsuit soon.
The land itself is starved of runes.
Runes?
Simply put...
...the source of all life.
Hmm...
You're so dead.
Looks like it won't bloom this year either.
No!
How tragic.
This is the sacred tree.
Guardian of our village.
Oh.
Before the collapse, it gave us gorgeous flowers every year.
I think it's ominous now.
Oh.
That captivating sight earned us another moniker.
Village of ever-blooming flowers.
Unfortunately.
Oh.
Do you really plan to cut it down?
Indeed.
Takumi's inspection revealed that the roots have already begun to rot.
I was gonna say.
It's probably rotting.
Best to remove it before it falls.
And possibly injures someone.
Oh.
How realistic.
That's so sad.
This is so...
This is too real.
I'm afraid so.
Like that house.
Legend says that a very beautiful buxom deity once called this tree her home.
What a buxom deity.
Not that any of us have laid eyes on her.
Thank you guys for the gifted.
I was barely older than Suzu when this tree last bloomed.
Hey, hey.
A boing boing deity?
So...
Wait.
Suzu's just like me for real.
What's a buxom?
Good question.
Some kind of fruit, I think.
It means she got big ol' biddies.
Why you just so casually describe the goddess like that?
What?
I'll say good question.
Aww.
There's Yae.
Yae.
Hello.
Oh.
Goodbye.
And so our population drops again.
Aww, they look so sad.
From what I hear, the rest of Azuma fares little better than our village.
Oh.
I wish her well out there.
Who all is left?
Great guardian.
If you're listening, I hope you recover soon.
And when you do, please bless us with your beautiful flowers again.
Aww, they're so cute.
That does it.
I'll be the one to revitalize our village.
Yeah.
Yeah, you.
I'll convince plenty of customers to visit my tea shop and try the best Dongo in us.
Dango!
That's the spirit.
Let me help.
Oh, yeah.
We got...
She's our booth babe.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Something's bothering Suzu.
I should ask her about it.
Main quest.
Talk to Suzu.
But what if I want to explore just a little bit?
Okay.
Just a little.
Let's...
Let's look around the village a bit.
Can I break this?
I got some more weeds.
Why are they keeping that in the box?
Wait.
I'm collecting medicinal herbs.
Oh, gosh.
I love just hoarding plants.
You know?
Where did these come from?
I just took...
I just swept this morning.
Give me plants.
Give me...
Oh, yeah.
Give me the collectibles.
Green grass.
She's just...
Literally on her hands and knees.
Just picking little blades of grass.
You got this, Minto.
Touch grass.
Oh, wow.
Our turnips.
Days until harvested.
Okay, we'll get them tomorrow.
Ah.
Sorry.
I yawn.
Not because I'm bored.
But because...
I'm jet lagged.
How long has that sacred tree watched?
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
I can't speak up.
Oh, I'm on auto still.
The cherry blossoms tend to steal the spotlight.
But the true charm of our little village is that we have a wide variety of beautiful flowers that are always in bloom.
Oh.
Yeah.
Well, they were.
This one's in bloom right here.
Like I can hide in...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, can I crouch?
No.
I was gonna say...
I can trick people into saying that I'm like the...
The goddess.
What is this?
Hope you're well.
Thank you.
Yeah.
What a pleasant place.
I always enjoy it here.
With...
What?
With the sunshine and all?
What do I want for dinner?
That's a good question.
Can I go inside?
Wait, what's this?
Inspect.
You know how it's...
Oh, it's her tea house!
Plus...
6 AM?
The times are the same.
It doesn't matter.
Weekday?
Holiday?
Doesn't matter.
I don't think we can go inside yet though.
Oh.
I think sitting here though and...
Drinking the tea Iroha made for me...
Oh, little Jizo.
Inspect.
A Jizo statue.
It is watching over the children perhaps.
Cute.
What's in here?
I'm going inside.
Oh.
It seems like someone must have been living here until just recently.
Could this have been Yai's house?
Oh.
What about you?
No one.
Empty.
What's in here?
Take it.
Come on.
Minto slash.
Minto hit.
Minto attack.
I'm going to rock climb.
I can't rock climb.
Wait.
Oh.
Wait, can I...
What's out of here?
Don't...
I do it so that you guys don't do it.
MAN Um hi- Don't...
Don't...
Don't be like me, in theces.
implemented.....
Yeah but there's like, a little ledge down there.
It's like, begging to be...
You know?
It's begging to be explored.
I swear it.
Poor Suzu will always have something on her mind.
Sorry, Suzu, you can't give me...
You can't give me a place to explore, then...
Oh, did we do this too?
Maybe that's why people are leaving the village.
Because we destroy their homes.
Minto the beta tester.
Can you look up at the birds?
Are there birds?
I see no birds.
Wait, I can destroy this.
More weeds!
Thank you for your sacrifice.
Yes, yes.
Wow, this is a fancy house.
What place is this?
This is Sakaki's house.
It's pretty nice.
That's exactly what I said.
And Sakaki's plants.
Surprisingly, he takes rather meticulous care of it.
Thank you for the gift, dude.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Okay, you think I'll die here too?
Wait, can I?
Oh, I can't cut the bamboo.
Do it.
I'm not chicken.
I'm no chicken.
Speaking of chicken.
You know what I watched for the first time?
Ever on the plane?
On my way back from Japan?
Hmm?
Is this the carpenter?
Oh, is the carpenter closed?
I suppose they must have left the village.
Dang, we don't even have a carpenter.
John Wick?
Yeah, I watched John Wick.
I already talked about that.
I watched Back to the Future for the first time.
Can you believe it?
I've never watched that movie before.
And Back to the Future 2.
Nah, for the first time.
So, thinking of the chicken.
No one calls me chicken.
Doesn't seem like anyone's inside.
Could it be abandoned?
Wow.
Sounds like free real estate to me.
Sounds like...
Look at all these open houses.
Alright.
Suzu!
What's on your mind?
What you thinking about, little girl?
Quick.
Oh.
Uh, it was a...
Cool.
Wait.
Hold on, Suzu.
I gotta get the weeds from the box.
She looks so troubled.
What's wrong?
What's wrong, Suzu?
I think...
I think this is really me.
Can I ask a favor?
Go ahead.
I'll turn auto back on.
So, Lily.
Whenever I play outside the village, I keep seeing this really weird animal.
Weird.
How?
It's round, and white, and fuzzy, and just...
Really weird.
Will you help me look for it?
Pretty please?
Hmm.
Of course.
We must make sure it's not a monster.
Really?
She's so cute.
Let me show you where I usually see it.
Okay.
She's taken off.
Bond strengthened with Suzu.
Oh, I can sprint.
Wait, that's not...
Oh.
I saw it around here yesterday.
Bright white, and covered in fluff.
Fluff.
A wooly, maybe?
Wooly.
Come this way.
Yeah, sheep, maybe?
Destination marker.
An orange destination marker.
Shows your current goals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Open the map from the camp menu for a wider overview.
Okay.
Cool.
Um...
Why is the MC scantily clad?
Because they gave me bathing suit DLC.
And it would just be so rude of me not to use it.
Withered grass.
What are you guys doing?
Sorry about Suzu.
She's got a short attention span, so just humor her for a bit, okay?
Okay.
A weird animal in the village.
Can't say I've seen anything of the sort.
Perhaps it hides from all but the innocent eyes of a child.
Oh, wow.
It could be you, Grandpa.
Your hair is white.
What if it's him?
Who are you?
My stomach's gnawing on my spine?
I should probably get some dinner.
I've never heard that expression ever once in my afterlife ever.
What?
My stomach's gnawing on my spine.
That's so metal.
Oh.
We got a lumber.
I saw it here two days ago.
He's all real Greek.
I think.
It had super big horns.
Curvy ones.
Orange.
She's cute, so it's fine.
True.
Horns?
That it can't be a wooly.
Maybe a buffamoo?
Buffamoo.
Not here, either.
Let's go this way next.
Is this a gacha game?
No.
Hmm.
Just anime.
Just this way.
Delicious spine.
Okay, there's no fall damage, maybe.
I saw it around here three days ago.
I gasped real loud.
Which must have scared it, because then it flew away.
Flew?
It can fly?
Okay.
Flying rules out buffamoo.
Thank you so much for the fight.
Good to take you.
This is a monster I've never seen before.
Oh.
Look at, look at Suzu's face.
I can't find it anywhere.
Hey, he's so cute.
But I know I saw it, I swear.
Thank you.
I believe you.
Do you want to keep looking?
Suzu?
Time to come inside.
Iroha's calling me.
I better go home, even if I don't want to give up yet.
It's okay, because we still have tomorrow.
Can we play with me again tomorrow?
Of course.
Meantow.
Yay!
See you then!
See you then.
Say it, I better get some rest back at the dragon shrine.
Okay.
They say all kinds of beasties.
Indeed.
Wait, hold on.
The beasties.
Oh, beasties, get up to mischief at this hour.
So keep an eye out.
Wait a second.
I kind of want to see if I can go outside the gate.
Wait.
What?
It was not this way.
Over here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're running, we're running, we're running, we're running.
It seems unwise to venture outside right now.
Aw, man.
Nobody ever lets me have fun.
Nobody ever lets me do what I want to do.
Wait, where am I?
Well, here.
All right.
Time to eepy sleepy.
Ending the day.
Sleeping restores your HP and rune points.
RP.
Staying up too late makes you sleepy.
Gradually draining your HP before you fall unconscious.
Yeah.
It's too real.
Sleep in your bed before this happens.
Wait.
How late can we stay?
I kind of want to...
I want to...
I want to fall unconscious.
We're getting that good sleep then, you know?
I mean, this cute today is...
Well?
He...
Heed me.
Turn on auto again.
Please.
If you can hear my voice.
Sounds like...
Meantode.
Oh.
Jay Blossom.
Wait.
The tree is talking to us.
Where's...
What am I doing outside?
And what am I doing in a bikini?
Why she's pretty.
I'm an earthling.
A great shadow looms over this village.
My life force is all but spent.
It's the Buxom Lady.
I bid you act in my stead.
Oh?
Me?
She's the Buxom Lady.
I offer you my stead.
A sacred treasure.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Wield its Kamiwaza with your dance.
Not the Kamiwaza.
I'm doing salvation to this village.
I beg of you.
Oh, yeah.
Ooh.
It's a little...
It's a little drum.
The creature.
Hey!
Up and at him, partner.
Come on.
Let's go.
Oh, boy.
Guys.
I kind of...
I kind of hate animal mascots.
Oh.
Oh, but he's really cute, actually.
No.
What are you?
A creature.
Was that called for?
Don't tell me you forgot your own partner.
Wait.
Is that the dragon?
Partner?
The dragon turned into...
You're kidding me.
You seriously don't remember?
Oh, well.
Guess it's no surprise you wouldn't recognize me looking like this.
Looking like this.
White.
Fluffy.
Looking like this.
Flying.
You're the weird animal.
Uh-oh.
Excuse me?
Chopper energy.
I'm a dragon.
A descendant of the Mihoshihabaki.
Oh.
I am the ivory one who soars the heavens.
Mokoshiro.
Moko.
Um.
Could you repeat that?
It's the god.
Come on.
I'm not saying all that again.
Ugh.
Just call me whatever you want.
Dragon's got a weird swimsuit skin.
I don't like Wolby.
Wolby.
That's your best name for the descendants of a dragon god?
You don't like it?
I don't think so.
Fine.
Whatever.
Listen.
You and I have a much bigger fish to fry at the moment.
The way he talks.
We've got to track down the black dragon before it drains all the runes from Azuma.
What black dragon?
Ugh.
Let's shave him.
Please tell me you're pulling my leg.
Why else did I make you an earth dancer?
An...
Earth dancer.
Dramatic bars.
An...
Right.
Earth dancer.
And this is that divine instrument from my dream.
Oh.
I'm supposed to use it in some sort of dance.
Oh, yeah.
You remember now.
Great.
There you are.
It's me.
We've got trouble.
Uh-oh.
Some kind of shadowy monster is attacking the village.
No.
I'm not done talking yet.
Dramatic pause.
It's funny with the auto on.
Uh-oh.
Well, good thing we don't have to search so far for the black dragon.
It came to us.
Easy peasy.
Game over.
He planted...
Wait.
He just planted his own tree.
It's the one from my dream.
Stop!
That's my turnip!
Oh my god.
A blimp?
Suddenly.
There you are.
Melo.
Black dragon spotted.
Roger.
Hard port.
Huh?
Ready and...
Fire!
She's cute, yeah!
The horns!
Aim for the horns!
Well, you're gonna tell them their weakness, but you don't even remember what it is.
Oh!
That's what I said!
Oh, she's cute!
Oh!
Look out below!
Dramatic face.
She's so pretty.
She's so, so pretty.
They're from Room Factory 5!
No kidding?
Oh my god, she's got...
She's got horns!
Not exactly.
She cute.
She was a baby in the N5 and now...
Grazie!
Oh!
I see!
Mamma mia!
Oh!
He's gonna...
He has his own little intro!
Mauro!
Adventurer who sails the skies!
And this young lady is my traveling companion!
The esteemed archaeologist...
Hina!
Oh!
You keep saying it wrong!
It's Hina!
Hina!
You always insist on calling me Mallow, no?
Hello?
That's a nickname!
Doesn't count!
Oh!
Oh my god!
She's so cute!
Mysterious archaeologist...
Hina!
She's so stickin' cute!
When they get so close to the screen, I get doki doki!
At any rate, that black dragon gave us quite the runaround!
How did you know it's weakness?
Uh, lucky guess!
Well, um...
Hey!
Iroha!
Are you alright?
Yeah!
Suzu and I are fine!
But...
The sacred tree?
Oh no!
Uh oh!
Sakaki!
Ah!
Thank the gods you're safe!
What was that black dragon?
To think it would descend upon our poor little village.
Uh...
That dreadful creature has sown calamity across all of Azaman.
Oh...
That's...
They say...
It spreads blight bloom spores.
Blight bloom spores.
Plants that absorb the land's ruins.
Ew!
Time to sweep it up!
The land has been weakened enough already.
At this rate...
Oh no!
I know how to do chores.
We're still...
Our sacred tree was caught in the crossfire.
The damage is too great.
Our village will never recover.
We'll never financially recover from this.
You're cutting it down?
But...
If we lose the tree...
Then...
We have no choice, child.
Best to remove it before it harms someone.
Think of the Taurus.
Where's the...
Hm?
How do I explain this?
Uh...
The tree's god spoke to me in my dreams.
Do we sound like a crazy person?
Or...
Let me try something.
I'll save it, I promise.
I think we can go full Delulu.
Let's try going Delulu.
Huh?
Well...
Considering we discussed her...
I can't say I'm surprised.
If only I were so lucky.
I like how his name is actually Wolby.
Like they just assigned that to him.
You just...
Ditched me.
Not a thought behind those eyes.
Just...
Very well.
I, the great Wolby...
Descendant of Mihoshi Habaki...
Shall impart my wisdom unto you.
Okay.
First things first.
We've gotta heal the land.
Follow me!
Easy peasy.
He looks so excited.
Oh!
Nobody else is coming.
Come to think of it...
You said the god gave you an instrument in your dream, right?
Uh huh.
Right.
She asked me to save this village in her place.
Then it's time to put that thing to good use.
The god of spring oversees this village.
Her domain includes healing and mirth.
Ooh.
Let's start by giving these blighted trees a healthy dose of cheer.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Receiving a sacred treasure from a god lets you use your rune points.
Oh!
To perform their unique ability known as a kamiwaza.
Use the drum dance to heal or spur growth and plant life.
As well as restore blighted land to its former glory.
Oh.
Okay.
Seemed easy.
I think.
Maybe.
So I go to a tree.
Prosper.
Not that.
We eat.
And then we equip.
And then I...
On to the next.
Oh!
Wow.
That was really effective.
What about this one?
No?
We don't care about that tree?
We don't care about that one?
Okay.
What a mess that black dragon made.
Uh...
Oh!
Wait!
Did I use all my rune points?
Snack on this if you run low.
Oh.
Just let time go by and your rune points will recover on their own.
Okay.
Oh, I can move during these too.
I didn't realize.
I got some pickled turnips.
Delish.
Open the camp menu and go to inventory.
Use items.
Okay.
Or they'll naturally regenerate.
But it was only like three!
Why did he get mad at me?
It worked!
It was only like three points.
So dramatic.
Alright.
Oof!
This place was hit pretty hard.
Get dancing!
Okay!
Oh!
I couldn't see it.
Ooh!
Um...
Hmm.
Nobody has anything to say.
Aww!
Me!
This...
PRC!
You're fine!
Oh!
Let's talk to her.
Look at all the damage it's done this time.
We couldn't do enough to stop it.
Oh!
Can I take it?
Take their boat?
Oh, wait.
I can.
I can inspect it.
Mauro's airship.
Attempted to sneak a ride.
See how?
That's what I'm saying.
We should.
We can.
With stopping us.
Truly.
And...
Looting and plundering.
Hmm.
Gosh, the weed's here.
No.
Sticking away.
I swept.
Literally.
Just yesterday.
I can see Sakaki turning into Master Roshi.
Right.
Okay, let's get this tree.
And collect this plant.
Orange grass.
Oh, interesting.
The sacred tree's roots probably reach every corner of this village.
We've gotta help it out by reviving the earth first.
Okay.
There.
That oughta perk things right up.
Let's head back to the sacred tree.
It already looks so much better.
Like, it already...
It's looking way better.
What was gonna be built here, I wonder?
Okay, back to the sacred tree.
Tree, tree, tree, tree, tree.
What?
What's this?
Oh.
More grass.
Okay.
Now for the finishing touch.
Use the dance of bonds to restore power to the god.
Hold on.
Do you see?
How much grass is around here?
Ugh.
Chores.
Okay, I was gonna say, it's not this.
This is the dance.
Or...
This is the bonds.
Yeah, dance of bonds.
Eka!
So quiet.
Just watchin'.
I offer these humble words.
Great entity which dwells within this tree.
May your divine glory shine forth and bless us all forevermore!
May your divine glory and your divine buxom.
What?
Amazing!
Ooh!
Seeing so many!
Oh, she's so cute.
So pretty!
It's so pretty!
Spud.
Diferous.
Is that...
What I think it is?
I knew it.
The gods must have sent you to us for a reason.
I...
I barely did anything.
Like, you've just bloomed the tree that hasn't bloomed in 50 years!
No?
Yours truly!
And you are...
Ah!
And the ivory one who soars the heavens!
Mokoshiro!
Descendant...
Of...
Bihoshi Havati!
Nickname...
Woolby!
Lord Woolby!
You both have my deepest gratitude for your tireless efforts.
Oh!
There she is!
She's gracing us!
With her presence!
Wow!
He was a...
Peaceful god of spring and mirth...
Ulalaka!
Wait...
Is she...
Can...
Can we also...
Wait...
The bull...
Wow!
Um...
I'm a fan.
Yes?
Oh no...
How glad I am to meet you in person.
From within this tree, I preside over Azuma's springtime and merriment.
My followers call me the joyful elegance of spring.
You may address me as Ulalaka.
Ulalaka!
Divine Ulalaka!
Forgive my influence!
I had no idea you truly resided within this tree.
Ulalaka!
I have seen and felt how dearly you care for this village.
Wow!
How did he know?
Were I in your position, I surely would have done the same.
You honor me too greatly.
How did he know?
Ulalaka!
Earth dancer.
Allow me to thank you once again.
You're welcome.
In fact, might I borrow the drum I bestowed upon you?
Oh.
Yeah.
There you go.
Oh.
It's the exact same.
I have released the sacred treasure's inner power.
Oh.
Your drum dance should be more effective now.
Ooh.
Her JP Seiyu is one of my favorite.
I'm very curious what she sounds like in Japanese.
I lost much of my divine strength along with my runes.
Please, Earth dancer.
I ask that you save Azuma in my stead.
Restore spring to this village.
And to the land itself.
Hmm.
That's above my pain grade.
Wait.
Will we get paid?
That's a God-given request.
You're not really going to turn her down, are you?
I'm asking too.
Please, save our village.
Please.
Oh.
I'm not sure how much I can do.
But I'll give it my best effort.
I'm gonna look up what her Japanese voice actress is.
Oh.
Wait.
Great going.
You've unlocked the power of...
Ooh la- Ooh la la...
Ooh la la...
...goes sacred treasure.
Still, you can't use everything it's capable of right away.
Ha ha ha.
So pretty.
The more you use it, the better you'll handle it.
Keep that up and you can eventually draw out all its latent power.
Wow.
That might be...
Sorry.
I didn't mean for that angle.
I was looking at him.
Ha ha ha.
Sorry.
That might be a little hard to wrap our head around.
Which is why we have the handy dandy skill tree.
Ooh.
There's a skill tree.
All right.
They just called it what it is.
Since we're all...
Since we're here and all, why don't we try drawing out some of its power right now?
Go to the drum dance skill tree and unlock the shock wave skill.
Ha ha.
Unlocking nodes in a skill tree lets you learn new techniques and increase your stats.
Unlocking nodes with XP.
Which you can earn by performing a variety of different actions.
Nice.
Use the shock wave from the drum dance to stop enemies on their tracks.
Press...
Press right click repeatedly to increase its impact.
Ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
Okay, hold on.
I was gonna look up.
Hey.
Maybe we should go talk.
And ask the village chief Sakaki.
Wait a second.
Oh my gosh.
He's already...
On my butt.
Okay.
Ooh.
Wait.
Rune Factory.
I'll try and avoid spoilers, obviously.
I won't read anything.
I just want to see what are...
Who are voice actresses in Japanese?
Oh.
Reina Ueda.
Yes, yes, yes.
I looked it up.
Okay.
Anyway.
Now I kind of want to look up everybody.
Could that power be?
No.
I'll have to research this further.
Wait.
Now everybody can move back.
Yae chose the wrong day to move, huh?
What a bozo.
Wait.
It's sparkling even.
Cute.
What a dummy.
All he had to do was wait one more day.
And it would have been all good.
This guy wasted no time to read his book.
Good morning.
He comes over and laughs at me and reads his book.
The older I get, the earlier my mornings become.
Ah, well.
The early bird gets the worm, after all.
What is with old people and waking up early, huh?
What is that?
Good morning.
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I'm so sorry.
I already slept so much last night.
I went to bed at 10pm.
The sun going through the leaves is so pretty.
And then...
And then I woke up at 11pm.
And I was like, what time is it?
Thinking it was like the next day.
And then I was like, oh, I only slept for one hour.
Uh oh, I hope I can go back to sleep.
Then I went back to sleep.
Then I woke up at 4am.
And then I was like, oh, I can't sleep.
I think this is it for me.
And then I stayed up until 6am.
Then I fell asleep at 6am.
Then I woke up again at 10am.
I was like...
I would wake up every time.
I'd be like, what...
What year is it?
Oh, golly.
I'm so jet lagged.
This is bad.
Maybe I should have been drinking...
Maybe I should be drinking tea that has...
Caffeine.
Why is she crying?
Restore spring to this village.
And to the land itself.
Splendiferous.
Mauro.
Oh, what a beautiful sight.
My trip to Azuma was worth it for that alone.
Thanks.
I'm going to see if there's anything I can do for the village too.
Wow.
The flowers bloomed.
The god of spring is so cool.
My living a long life has its perks.
The legends about the buxom beauty certainly didn't exaggerate.
He's blushing.
Mr. Having witnessed your powers of restoration.
I'd like to ask you a favor.
Minto.
I don't know.
Would you consider taking my place as chief and revitalizing our village?
That's a huge ask.
Everyone here knows you.
You're still on the plane.
If you need any help.
Everyone here knows you, yeah like all three people.
You're acting like this is a... this is a real village.
This is... Of course, I would hope all three people know who I am.
What do you say?
Do I have a choice or... I'd love to.
What are your calling in life?
I... I wouldn't go that far.
Wonderful.
My sincerest thanks.
You've taken a load off my shoulder.
Gramps is gonna go retire.
Now then.
I shall entrust our village's future.
He's like finally a way out.
We'll take good care of it.
And Woobie is just... Wait, where is he going?
Wait.
Guess what?
I've got a little present for you.
Oh?
Do you tell?
What's this?
It's like now you can form!
Proof that you're a true earth dancer.
A terra-tiller.
With this, you can till new fields, grow crops, and develop the village as you please.
The terra-tiller is my sacred treasure.
So just like with Ulalaka's drum, you'll choose it from the list of sacred treasures in your inventory.
Okay.
Got it?
Good.
Now let's farm!
Let's farm!
Oh my gosh.
It's a reward.
Head to the development zone.
Wow.
Whoa!
Did she see that?
Ulalaka-sama?
Huh?
She says these turnips suck.
Woobie's like, first is village, then the world.
She's so pretty.
Sounds like a job for the new head honcho.
Yes.
She's right there.
I think she could hear her get a whisper.
And I hate seeing Ulalaka so sad.
Spoken like a true earth dancer.
I've already prepared everything you need.
So let's hop to it.
Okay.
Uh...
First things first, we've got to do something about the mess.
Okay.
Let's clear out everything that's in the way and make some farmland.
That'll give us a place to grow some great eats.
Two birds with one stone.
Oh yeah.
So...
Equipping the Terra Tiller.
We'll switch you to village builder mode.
Wait.
Can I build anywhere?
With the Terra Tiller equipped, you can hold...
Is that shift?
To remove any unneeded objects.
Let's try it.
Fields are...
But one type of terrain tile.
If you want to grow crops, you'll need to place field tiles first.
Remember that.
Our Terra Tiller.
First, we've got to clean up the place.
So like this.
And the rocks.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Much better.
If one fell swoop.
Yes.
Let's place some fields.
Okay.
Press...
What do you think that...
That is?
What is that button?
Tab?
Okay.
Press tab.
Maybe.
To bring up the building menu here, select what you want to place.
Then press F in the spot.
You want to place it.
Okay.
Tab.
Trusting you guys.
Oh, it is.
And we buy three...
Oops.
I missed a spot.
You've done this before, haven't you?
I guess you wouldn't remember.
All right.
We'll plant some seeds next.
Here.
Take these turnip seeds.
It's best to start with the basics.
Let's plant those suckers.
No, they're turnips.
Use F to plant seeds while facing a field.
Sorry.
Some people are probably...
Screaming at me like...
Minto!
Uh...
So then do I E again?
No.
Oh, tab.
Turnip.
F.
That's all I need to do.
I don't need to water them or anything.
Okay.
The first step to a green thumb.
Oh.
I spoke too soon.
We're gonna be rich, baby.
Yeah!
We're gonna be rich!
Water your fields daily.
Your seeds and crops won't grow without water.
Neglect them for too long or they just might wither away.
Press F.
Okay.
Not bad!
You can switch other characters to swimsuit too if you want to.
It unlocks at the start of the game.
It might be unlocked right now.
Wait, ow!
We'll go...
After this, we'll go to the temple and see.
To the...
Wardrobe.
Alright!
Oh, it's time for the harvest.
Just great.
Maybe not now, seeing as we only just planted them.
Eventually.
Oh!
Look at those turnips!
See the shriveled up ones?
And the others that are nearly ready to harvest?
Hey!
Why don't you plant the turnips, Vituper?
Maybe the drum dance of yours could revive the former and help the latter finish growing.
Oh...
Use the drum dance.
I was thinking that too.
I was like, what if we use the drum to...
To...
Help them grow.
The dance will only work on one...
On each target once per day.
Also used to revive withered crops.
Okay.
Use F...
F to...
Harvest fully grown crops.
They'll even produce...
Saints.
Okay.
My drum.
Alright.
Huh!
Oh!
Wow, that was extremely effective.
Wait, I thought it was only just...
Cute!
Okay.
Wow!
That's so nice that you don't have to let...
It has a range, obviously, but...
It's so nice that you don't have to do it one at a time.
Oh my goodness.
Oh...
That's a nice haul.
Hmm?
And you got some seeds.
Uh...
You'll get seeds when...
When harvesting crops.
That's important info right there, so make sure to remember.
Yes!
Now we gotta...
Ship them?
What do you mean, ship them?
Ship till you drop.
Wait, what do you mean we're shipping them?
Oops.
At least water's free.
Wait, uh...
So then...
If I...
Tab...
No.
E...
Tiller...
Tab...
Seed.
Let's replant.
Oh, this is so cozy.
It's making me sleepy.
I mean, I was already sleepy, but...
Like, water...
Water...
And...
Water the middle.
Okay.
That's what we're talking about.
Let's go to...
The shrine up here?
Hey!
Enough messing around!
Wait!
They won't let me.
I just wanna see if I can put everybody in swimsuits!
Um...
Put the turnips in the shipping shed.
Over here.
Oh, I was...
I was...
They're right next to it!
All of them?
Split quantity.
There we go.
Hehe.
Oh.
There we go.
Okay.
Yeah!
We'll keep some turnips for ourselves.
Alright.
Okay.
Um...
Good.
Any items placed in your shipping shed will...
Be...
Sold off automatically by the next morning, Netting you a profit.
This includes harvested crops.
So, any item!
Whatever I want.
What about all this grass I've got?
Nice.
Remember, toss anything you want to sell in here.
Once it ships, you'll earn a nice little profit.
Alright!
Put Woolby in there.
I wish.
Let's ship him away.
At least his design is very cute.
We're in the swing of things, so let's keep this ball rolling.
Oh!
We're out of field tiles already?
Yes!
Eh, no sweat.
We'll make some ourselves.
Uh...
First, we need the necessary materials.
Since I'm feeling extra generous, I'll provide them just this once.
Leave it to me!
All you gotta do is call me whenever you want to make tiles.
Okay.
Call Woolby.
To create the various terrain tiles you can use in village builder mode.
Okay?
I only have to call him.
Path recipe!
Oh no.
Rich soil.
Red soil.
Red
soil.
Oh.
Maybe I don't want to be up this early.
Alright!
Um...
No, I think we're good.
Yeah.
Since he gave me...
What?
Wait.
How do I get to it again?
Terrain tiles?
Wait, I thought I was gifted them.
Why is...
Why don't I have anything?
I don't want the path.
He gave me...
Do I have to make it from him first?
Call Woolby.
Oh, it's X.
Yes!
Alright!
Create terrain tiles.
So, which do you want to make?
Oh!
I see, I see.
Farmland.
Okay.
Um...
Six?
Okay.
Leave the next bit to me.
Great!
Let's keep working the fields at a steady pace.
Yes.
A true masterpiece, if I do say so myself.
Alright!
I'll just do everything I've taught you thus far.
First, throw down a field.
Plant some seeds.
All good.
You don't have to harvest them this time.
Here.
More turnip.
I just got turnip seeds.
Okay.
Let's do this.
Uh...
How...
Oh, here we go.
Building type.
Here we go.
Terrain tiles.
Okay.
Place.
Okay, okay.
Oh no, I'm gonna be uneven again.
Um...
No!
And seed.
How do you guys usually do this?
Are you like a water first then plant?
Or a plant first then water?
That's what I'm talking about.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much, Earth Dancer.
Excellent.
I skipped it.
Plant first.
Yes.
Then water.
This might just be enough.
Ah.
Cute.
What happened?
Our village leveled up!
Oh.
I feel like I just got a huge boost of energy.
Ulalaka's granted you her blessing.
Proof?
Positive that her divinity's back.
Wow.
Thank you, Ulalaka.
Ulalaka.
I have another request, Earth Dancer.
If you could spare the time...
Would you help me revitalize the village?
Everybody's asking me to revitalize the village.
Allowing me to assist you even further.
I think I already said yes, no?
Has the new village chief?
It would be my pleasure.
I'm gonna eat a...
A...
Voicemint.
I can't express how relieved I am to have an Earth Dancer like you.
Sorry, I have to hear me.
Eating it.
Hmm.
Creating fields and growing crops will revitalize the village, raising its village level.
As the village level increases, the god that watches over the village will regain their divinity...
And reward you with new blessings.
Speak to the god when the village is ready to level up.
Hmm.
Time to rest is now available.
Um, stop backseating me, Woobie.
I gotta water the plants.
Is that not so important?
And then also...
Uh, we can use this.
And...
Drum dance.
Wait.
I can't use it on these because...
Technically, I already use it on this plot today.
Even though it's new seeds.
I'll try it.
Oh!
Just...
Kidding!
Mm-hmm.
Then we can use this...
To...
Remove more stuff.
And we'll get...
We get soil for this.
And soil...
Allows us to do more fields, I believe.
Oops.
I messed up.
Uh...
What will the people do?
Um...
Uh...
How much money do I have?
Okay.
Ugh!
Chad's broken.
Oh, I think it is.
Hold on.
One moment.
I'll rescue you guys.
Maybe I can't rescue you guys.
And redo.
Uh...
There you go.
Okay.
What was this?
Ooh, secrets.
Profiles.
View a character's profile to check their likes and dislikes.
Okay.
What do you like, Iroha?
Ooh, nothing.
What?
Mm-hmm.
I see.
Ah-ha-ha!
You've grown closer to Iroha.
Your bod boosts Iroha's taunt skill?
Interesting.
Meh.
So I guess these guys are romance-able.
Because they're in red.
And then, they're like...
You can't even eat with the grandpa!
Sad.
Iroha has a tank.
Is that what it said?
Did I miss that?
Where do you see that?
Oh, because of taunt.
Oh, yeah.
I guess that makes sense, huh?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, wait.
We can see his skill.
He doesn't have any.
I don't think Kino does either.
Nope.
Okie dokie.
We...
We have...
Farmed.
We've danced.
We've...
Romanced.
Grandpa?
Oh.
You...
You've taken to a ravaged lands with such haste.
I will gladly join you, but with my back the way it is...
Well, I'm sure you understand.
Hmm...
Did all of this happen in one day?
It's a crazy day.
I would be exhausted.
You think I can...
Revitalize this tree?
Nope.
It was born this way.
It was born sad and...
Stickly.
Quick send support.
It's not broken!
Anymore.
When are we gonna fix that hole in the roof?
Are there no carpenters in this village or what?
Um...
Well, you know...
That's a good point.
Inventory management.
Okay.
Let's see if this works.
No way.
The...
The books of...
Deity.
Wowee.
Wait.
I don't know if I can look at this.
Isn't it so cute?
What is that on her arm?
What is that?
It's like a little mochi.
With her swimsuit.
So cute!
Wowee!
Fluffy tail.
Like a floatie.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like a mochi floatie or something.
It's so cute.
He's got one too, but...
Oh, it's a bird.
Pirate King over here.
Yay!
Now we can all feel normal because...
Everybody's in a swimsuit!
You just imagine the audience...
In a swimsuit.
And you don't feel so nervous anymore.
Exactly!
Yeah!
Everybody's naked!
Okay.
Oh, and then this shows us what our...
What our quests are.
Hold on, let's get rid of this.
I'm one of those types of people that...
That, like, has to...
Not check off, but if there's like a...
If there's like a little...
Notification, I gotta get rid of it.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
Time to rest.
What else was there?
What's in here?
Oh, here's the skill tree.
Oh.
What is this?
We'll never know.
Oh, here we go.
Kagura Dance Flower Blessings.
Surround the user with an aura that gradually heals all allies.
Okay.
Also brings wither trees back to life, which...
We do that anyway.
Bottom right still not in swimsuit.
Yeah.
It's not...
Summer, maybe.
I don't know.
Deals earth damage to all surrounding enemies while healing all allies.
Wait.
I can't tell which one would be better.
They both heal.
This one does damage and heals.
It's June already.
Oh.
You're so right.
When is summer?
I'm gonna Google.
When is the first day of summer?
First day of summer.
June 20th.
Soon.
See?
But it's not summer.
It's not summer yet.
It's still spring.
Silly.
Okay.
Which one do you guys think?
It...
Mendo.
I think this one.
I think we'll do flower storm.
Yes.
What do I...how do I do this?
Or...left click.
Okay.
Alright.
Cool, cool, cool.
Let's sleep.
Hmm.
Sleep.
I wish that were... Good night.
I want to sleep so bad right now.
I'm actually...I'm actually fading pretty fast.
Oh!
Wait, we got 10 points for walking.
When you go to sleep, you'll receive a breakdown of your actions that day.
Each category will be tallied up and you'll earn a cumulative amount of all-purpose experience points.
Oh!
And then we can unlock more stuff.
Wait, so we have 28 now.
I didn't faint.
I didn't faint and I didn't stay up late at all.
Are you so proud of me?
I don't think you should get a penalty for fainting.
I think you should get a doctor's appointment.
Because I don't think that's normal.
I think you...
Need to go see someone.
Get that checked out.
Very proud.
Yay!
I'm always proud.
Mmm.
Have a cookie.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
Actually, I have some ice cream I'm gonna eat after stream.
Harvesting and collecting.
I did a ton of that.
Oh, yeah.
I did, baby.
Morning!
What should we do?
Wait, today's weather.
Do you see that?
First set of ideas, why don't we go ask Sakaki if we can get help with anything.
Okay.
Or if we can help with anything.
Yeah, my islands are so heavy right now.
Like if I could, I could just sleep right here.
I could.
But I won't.
Because.
Um.
That's unprofessional.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Gather, gather, gather.
Oh.
I like the music change.
No, no, no.
Nothing.
Nothing?
Okay.
Looking for any...
Crates to shatter.
Any...
Um.
Any crates to shatter.
Any plants to pick up.
Oh, these look...
Okay, these are definitely gonna be done in like...
Here we go.
Three, two, one.
Cool!
Oh, and then we change to this.
That's right.
Where do we have to?
Actually, now I can't tell.
What if I just turn the whole...
What if I flatten the whole village...
And turn it all into turnip fields?
The turnip stonks...
Are going up.
Are high.
They're the highest they've ever been.
Oh, here I am.
Actually, let me try if it'll work.
Oh, I know how to equip it.
Okay, good to know.
Bye, bye, bye!
Absolutely.
With this...
Remove.
Remove this giant rock.
That's all we get is just rock times three.
Baby needs a new roof.
Look, it's...
Oh my gosh, there's even so many...
Who built this...
Okay, I know this rock was not here...
After they built the pathway.
This...
More weed.
Hi, ghost.
Hello.
If you click R3, you can use an overhead view.
Like this.
All right.
We're almost done with...
Nice.
Okay.
I'll get these rocks out of the way.
And then our...
Little area will be complete.
Oh, it's tea.
Wait, where'd I go?
Minto.
Minto, don't go.
That is handy.
That's very handy.
All right.
Let's replant all of our...
All of our seeds.
A level two turnip.
Why do we have that?
Why do we have a level two turnip?
How curious.
What makes a turnip level two?
What makes a turnip...
Is it a...
Certain deliciousness you don't get with a...
Level one turnip?
Like...
Hi, guys.
What is up?
Today, I'm gonna show you...
This level two turnip.
And how delicious it is.
I just did all this stuff in my backyard today.
I didn't look cute doing it though.
You have to put on a bikini.
That's the ultimate...
That's the reason it would...
You know, look better.
It's the ultimate weapon.
Trust me.
Trust me, bro.
Okay.
Oops, oops, oops.
Eh, you are in it.
Okay.
And then, we can use our drum again.
Guru!
Very good.
Wait, we have another bar...
Underneath our blue bar.
The RP bar.
Is that our X?
No.
Not XP, maybe.
I don't know.
Smashing like and subscribe for more turnip tips.
Yeah, welcome to turnip town.
Goodbye.
Bye.
Your...
Favorite...
VTuber.
Mean turnip.
Yeah.
Wow, we have a...
Oh my god.
We have 110.
Okay, we'll keep...
We'll keep like...
20 of them.
And the rest...
Off it to...
Money land.
Is there a spell for growing turnips?
Like a Moe Moe Kune style?
Maybe like a...
Well, I feel like Moe Moe grow.
Hmm.
I don't think that'd work.
The RP bar is your radish prospects bar.
Those are my radish points.
Oh, wait.
These are level two.
How much do they yield?
It's fine.
That's good.
Is she here?
She always wanted to open up this place...
But it's never open.
She's like...
Oh.
I love being a cafe owner...
Who doesn't...
Run their cafe.
Oh.
I forgot to turn off on.
Or turn on.
Or turn on auto again.
I forgot to have more turnips.
Oh, you've got to stop pushing yourself.
Can't you ask someone else to handle it for you?
Let me go, Iroha.
I may be old now.
But I was once known as the Demon Warden.
This is nothing for a...
Uh-oh.
My aching back.
My heart.
See?
My achy, breaky heart.
Is something wrong?
Let me know how I can help.
Demon Warden.
Dang.
Such a kind soul.
Our carpenter Takumi left a few days ago...
And hasn't come back.
Sakaki wants to go look for him.
I thought I'd ask him to repair the dragon shrine...
Since you're staying there.
He only left a couple days ago.
What stopped you from asking him months ago?
The curse of old age.
Oh.
Don't blame this on old age.
You're just lazy.
The chief could look for Takumi.
What do you say?
Oh.
Uh.
Yeah.
We'll look for him.
Great.
I'm glad you're so reliable.
Don't bully the grabb.
I'm reassuring to have you on the side.
Sorry.
Takumi went looking for materials...
...in the abandoned shrine to the north.
I'll ask the gatekeeper to open the way for you.
Yes, we get to leave.
Oh.
Before I go, take these with you.
Weapons?
They should prove useful for gathering materials.
Oh.
A cheap hammer.
Come on, Gramps.
That's all you got?
Is a cheap hammer?
You can mine ore deposits.
Oh.
And a common hatchet.
Chop wood.
Oh.
Preparing the dragon shrine could restore my power.
I might even regain my true form.
It sounds like he's about to cry.
Let's find this Takumi guy right away.
Okay.
Let's go outside.
I'm so excited to go outside.
Hoi.
Wait, so like...
I'm curious if this is the kind...
Oh.
Wait, they're not here yet.
Huh.
I was wondering if like...
Hmm.
Okay.
Iroha?
What's up, Iroha?
Something to matter?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, maybe we can only use them outside.
Iroha also starts searching for Takumi without a single onigiri for the road.
Onigiri?
You brought us some?
Tsunamayo?
Nope.
Oh.
I thought you should prepare them.
Hey!
How are you making us do the hard work?
Okay, we'll be a talking sense for once.
I mean, I'm just screaming to bring some when it suddenly hit me.
Do you even know how to make onigiri?
Oh, I'm not the one who owns the tea shop.
Now that you mention it...
That's not my job.
No.
Why is everyone in bikinis?
It's...
It's important.
DLC.
It's important, DLC.
You can't fight on an empty stomach.
Why do they look so sad?
With the right ingredients, you can cook at places like the Tea House or Izakaya.
Collect recipes to expand your cooking repertoire.
The cooking can restore HP and RP or grant temporary stat increases.
Cooking buffs expire the following day.
Onigiri.
Don't forget my portion, okay?
My stomach's rumbling like crazy.
Let's dig in.
Okay.
I thought it was going to be a mini game or something.
Thank you.
No kidding.
No, I'd argue that you had a great teacher.
The question is, why not?
So true.
As a reward for mastering the way of the onigiri, I'll give you extra ingredients to make more.
So generous.
Iroha!
It's so simple.
You only need a bonfire to prepare them.
Give it a try if you find one.
A bonfire?
Thank you for all the help, Iroha.
Good luck out there.
Bring back Takumi in one piece.
Okay.
I got some more steamed rice.
And salt.
Oh, the gate opened up.
That's exciting.
Oh my gosh.
We're going outside.
Spring Highlands.
Oh, there's that purple stuff.
Short swords are...
Short swords are well-balanced and easy to wield.
While their range isn't very impressive, they hit fast enough to keep enemies on the back foot, making it harder for them to strike back.
Press, press, press, press.
I know that combo.
Press, press...
Who am I going to attack right now?
Oh, wait.
So now...
Oh, I still don't have my...
I'm looking at the Jizo.
Let's go, partner!
He had...
Wait, I just stole his offering.
I think that's...
Bad luck, no?
Yikes.
Is that the combo?
What's this?
Drum dance.
Oh!
I can do it here.
Thief.
I didn't know!
What's this?
The music is so dramatic.
A treasure chest.
It looks like a picnic basket, actually.
Why not?
It's practically begging for us to take a peek.
Oh, I thought I was going to be a mimic.
A Ronin hat?
Wow.
Neat.
A hat.
Want to try it on?
Equip it on in the gear menu.
Oh, we can.
Wait, we can change our appearance at any time?
Okay, we don't have to wait for the wardrobe.
Let's see.
Okay.
Wait, is it...
Where's our hat?
What'd you find, huh?
Oh, she doesn't have it on.
Aw, man.
What's this say?
Beware of Oni.
Oh.
Oh, I hear him.
Do you hear him laughing?
Hee hee hee.
Wee!
You can do this, partner.
There.
Tap, tap.
We...
Oh.
We own that guy.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Criminal charges.
Stop.
You violated the law.
You can swap it in the appearance section.
We're styling right now, everybody.
Oh, yeah.
Is that a giant chicken?
Look at these oars.
Wait.
I want a mine.
I yearn for the mine.
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
That's dodge, yeah.
Excuse me.
I'm trying to keep this place nice and tidy.
Wait.
He's got a...
He's got an Oni-Niri.
Wait.
What's in here?
It's more salt?
This feels really disrespectful.
This feels like we're just stealing from them.
Come here.
Oh, gosh.
They're all coming here.
Yeah.
Wait.
I'm too strong.
I'm too good at this game.
Ha ha ha.
Chicken.
Oops.
Oh.
Oh, that's all we can get.
I like how it brightens the area when you...
Oh, so we don't...
Oh, that's actually so nice.
We don't have to switch, like, material.
We can just...
Or, like, the...
The tool.
It just does it automatically.
Oh, my gosh.
That's so nice, actually.
Because I feel like it would be a lot of switching.
Otherwise.
But you don't have to.
It's easy peasy.
Restored them just to chop them down.
Ah, Earth Dancer.
Oh.
Ooh.
Pickled turnips.
Wait.
He said something to me.
He's a frog.
Ribbit.
Hmm?
What was that?
Huh?
What's a kid doing outside the village?
Oh.
Hey, you there.
I saw you doing a weird dance.
Hey.
Anyway, you ever heard of frog statues?
Just, just who even are you?
I'm Kroki.
People call me the frog statue fanatic.
Wow.
Kroki.
It's like you were destined to be a frog statue otaku.
Hey.
But more importantly.
Do you like frog statues?
Do you?
I suppose so?
He's angry.
We like the recipes they give us.
Yay!
Ribbit.
After many long years of struggle and solitude...
I finally met another soul who shares my hobby.
Aww.
You're way too young to be that...
To be true.
For that to be true.
Frog Bert.
No, it's Kroki.
That's like...
Frog Bert and...
Doki.
Doki as a crow.
Ship name.
Kroki.
As a matter of fact, I'm a huge frog statue fan.
The kid doesn't like frogs.
He just likes the statues.
Well, the fanatic part of your name says it all.
What?
Ribbit?
How do you know my name?
I love him.
You mentioned it like 10 seconds ago.
Still, how could I not like them?
Those bulging eyes.
The cool, damp feel as you run your fingers over them.
Kroki Bert.
Everything about them fascinates me.
You okay?
Oh.
By the way, I have a favor to ask.
From one fan to another.
What is it?
As a true frog statue fanatic, my duty is, naturally, to learn about every frog statue in Azuma.
Hmm.
But I can't do it all by myself, no matter how much I wish I could.
I am bound by the bane of my existence.
Curfew!
I mean, you are still a kid.
My parents don't let me out here because they say it's way too dangerous.
So I sneak out instead.
We can't have that.
Please don't.
Your parents have a point.
Yeah.
Kroki the frog here with Kroki the crow.
I know, I know.
I'll go straight home after this.
But could you let me know if you find any more frog statues?
Tell me about their location and shape.
Size, feel, smell, taste, everything.
Hmm?
What was that last one?
Well...
Please.
I'm begging you.
Understood.
Oh, okay.
We're gonna taste the frog?
Yay!
Ribbit, I knew I could count on you.
You can usually find me in Spring Village.
Let me know whenever you find a frog statue.
Um...
Find enough and I'll give you some treasure I discovered.
Huh?
Really?
Yeah.
Only makes sense to reward you for your work.
After all, more frog statues means more happiness.
Okay.
You can do it!
Great.
Thanks a bunch.
Okay.
We'll get some recipes.
And I saw this baby.
Cheap cloth.
Let's go.
Wait, what's here?
Oh, we can chop the wood here.
Ooh, what'd you find, huh?
Some cherry blossoms.
Oh!
The entrance to the abandoned truck.
Oh, yeah.
Good stuff, partner.
Thank you.
I am pretty good, huh?
That's not what he said.
That was some heavy-duty stuff.
Another picnic basket.
Rich soil.
More red soil.
All right, let's go.
Wait, I missed this.
Vinegar?
What's that doing here?
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Don't I need three?
Three?
Okay.
We gotta wait for our RP to...
to...
come back.
What's over here for now?
What is that?
Yeah, we're...
we're out of...
radish point.
Oh?
Secret.
Oh my god.
Earth Dancer.
Recipe.
Rolled egg recipe.
I want some rolled egg right now.
Sweet rolled egg.
Sweet mama.
That's all I want right now.
Yummy.
See, it pays to explore, everybody.
Sometimes we get recipes for yummy eggy.
Box full of dirt?
Not questioned.
Pot full of vinegar?
Questionable.
And suspicious.
Yes, very.
Oh, what's there?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I think I'm falling.
Oh, wonderful.
The bridge is out.
I suppose I won't be getting across here until it's fixed.
Way to go, Minto.
Oh.
She's so...
She's so talented in every way.
In every way possible.
Forget leg day.
We all...
We all care about ankle day.
Oh.
Dragon.
Warping to save statues.
Nice.
It's been a minute since I've saved.
I think there's auto-saving in this game, but, you know, always good to also make manual saves.
Very nice.
Abandoned shrine.
Sounds kind of spooky.
Whoa.
Oh, man.
Talk about creepy.
Awesome.
Look at her just looking at him like...
What?
Wobi.
Are you scared?
Stop being such a baby.
No?
Come on.
Be serious.
You think a dinky place like this could scare a great and powerful dragon?
I just don't want to have to clean up after you wet yourself.
Dang!
Oh.
Good thing that guy is hidden in plain sight.
Minto, did you use your eyes?
What'd you find, huh?
Nothing for you, Wobi.
Back.
Back, you foul beast.
Ooh.
Hide.
Pauldron.
Okay.
It's armor, I guess.
Can we not pass until we...
Oh, monster barriers.
I was gonna say, can we not pass until we...
Until we...
Um...
Defeat the monsters.
Just like another game.
We're trapped.
Indigo grass.
That guy looks straight at me.
Can I...
I wish I could sneak up on...
Do a sneak attack, you know?
It's fine.
We can handle these guys.
Oop.
Okay, come here.
Oop, oop, oop.
Ouchie, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I was trying to dodge.
Okay, now I can loot in plunder from their little camp.
Lost by a treasure.
Energy potion.
Ooh.
Sounds good.
Take all their vinegar.
Nothing else that they got?
That's it?
Oh, I saw another one in the distance.
Finally getting hang of your weapon, eh?
I forget that I have...
My drum, too, that I can use.
What are the short sword...
Skill tree?
Oh, I have it on auto still.
Let's see.
Um...
Charge attack.
Ooh.
What if I don't want that?
What if I...
Oh, wait.
That's all I got.
Yeah, we should equip the armor, huh?
Okay, we hold it.
We should be in a bit better shape now.
Oh.
Did you know that your drum dance can also help?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did that.
We'll restore HP to you and anybody.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was R...
Right click, I think.
Drum, dance.
Drum, drum, drum.
Easy.
I think so.
Oh.
Left click.
Okay.
So it's R left click.
That's what it was.
Um...
What was I going to do?
Oh.
I was going to see our new gear.
Oh, yeah, I can put it on.
Equipment.
There we go.
We're styling.
That guy is just chilling.
I'm going to ruin his day.
Oh.
Oh, but I have no...
I have no more RP.
I forget about it.
Miso.
Mommy.
Well dressed now.
We're getting there.
We're building an outfit.
Obviously.
What's this?
More Miso.
Okay.
I guess I could eat the onigiri, huh?
We could eat the onigiri for...
For energy and stuff.
That guy coming after me.
Wait.
Easy.
Oh.
Okay.
Can I climb?
No monkeying around, I suppose.
There was another guy up here, wasn't there?
My eyes deceive me?
I suppose so.
And a frog.
So very...
Inconspicuous.
What...
What recipe?
Grilled onigiri.
Sounds yummy.
Okay.
So, if I...
Let's see.
I want to restore my...
RP.
So let's...
Chomp.
Oh, this only heals...
Okay.
This is...
So, the pickled turnips...
Restores our RP.
Oh, wait.
Eat it.
There you go.
The rice heals.
So anything...
So...
Some things heal.
We got an eggy.
Gonna use that for our sweet eggy.
Okay.
Okay-do-key.
Oh, ambush!
And then...
Let's try this.
We even got like a little...
Animation for it.
Nice.
That was sick.
Nope.
Ouch.
I tried.
Sometimes I wish I could...
I guess you have to like dodge backwards like...
Like that, I guess.
Did we just take an offering from Jesus at you?
Yeah, don't...
Don't take...
Yeah.
What'd you find, huh?
Nothing for you, woobie.
Red grass.
Oop!
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop!
Boop, boop, boop!
Ow!
Wait.
Oh.
Hold on.
This would be...
Uh...
R...
Oh, I don't have enough!
Oh.
Dang.
Bird came after me.
Time to finish them off!
I did.
I did that.
I finished them off.
This has a real threatening aura.
But I also sense a human presence.
Someone's...
I sure hope Takumi didn't end up as some monster's lunch.
Wait.
We got cabbage.
Maybe these fresh fruits and vegetables grow big and ripe...
One day bring someone joy.
Azuma Horticulture Club!
Okay.
That's kind of cute.
The cabbages.
They're free!
What do we get?
Stone sculpture recipe.
Delicious.
Yeah.
For our minerals, obviously.
Obviously.
For...
For our...
Uh...
Yeah.
Look at that chicken.
He's climbing.
Hmm.
You think they'll notice me if I start mining?
Oh.
Yes, they will.
Ow!
Woo!
We parried!
Oh!
No.
Oh, yeah, baby!
We're too strong!
Dog!
Okay, back to mining.
Are you beefier than usual or is it just me?
Back to mining?
You can't just call a girl beefy!
Holy!
Preserved bonito.
He's like, yeah, you're so beefy, Minto.
Thanks for...
Now I have a complex.
Cheap bracelet.
I wish I had a girl to call beefy.
Wait, is he coming back up or...
What's he doing?
Can he come back up?
Where is he?
Where's the chicken?
Oh, we can actually hear the...
Like...
The music now.
What the recipe?
A bench.
And that's our fiber.
I like it.
Where'd the bird go?
Bird.
Wait, now...
Oh, there he is.
He was saving that up.
He was saving...
Thank you, Al.
We could sit by the fire.
Oh!
This is how we cook?
Let her cook.
I'm gonna cook some eggy.
I'm starving.
Heal 70 HP and...
Might.
Pickled turnips.
Let's cook that.
Wait, we can do five?
And make it extra delicious.
Aw, I was hoping there would be an animation.
But that's okay.
Me too, actually.
I'm actually kinda hungry too.
Don't forget my portion, okay?
Come on.
Don't just wave that under my nose.
Let me have some too.
Hmm.
You're so desperate.
Will be there.
Inspect.
Touching a lantern, charge the runes with...
Wait.
Touching a lantern, charge with runes will restore some of your rune points.
No kidding?
Oh, I need that.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, cool.
Did I look in here?
Here's a good spot.
Wanna take a quick breather?
Nope.
Okay, this is just screaming boss, huh?
Huh.
Let's, um...
Maybe we should take a breather.
Okay, let's, uh...
Let's eat some snack.
And, uh...
I don't think we need to restore 70.
That feels like a little...
Much, no?
No?
Nah, we're fine.
Take who's out.
Oh, I forgot to turn back on, Otto.
Oh.
Ruby, stay back.
Haunt.
Peter.
The horse.
Bosses have high defense, which makes it difficult to damage them through normal means.
So one strategy is to fill up their stun gauge.
Once the gauge is full, you'll immobilize them and deal much more damage.
Each boss has a unique weakness.
Attacking them with their elemental weakness or striking their weak point will stun the gauge faster.
You can do this, partner.
Woo!
Okay.
Hey!
This...
Oh my god!
Go, go, go, go!
What's his weak point?
Ah!
Nice spawned.
You got him good!
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Oh.
I'm just getting...
getting him in the butt.
Boop, boop, boop.
Ouchy.
Oh, dang it.
That would've been a perfect...
Ah!
Oh!
Okay.
My charge attack.
That's right.
I forgot I had that.
And then, uh...
R and this.
Divine Death.
It's OP!
Holy cow!
Wow!
It's OP!
Well done!
Dang!
Now to find Takumi.
He might've hidden somewhere to escape that thing.
Dang!
What?
Freaking nuked him.
Yeah!
Oh.
Round two?
Huh?
This guy again?
No kidding?
Moonen Musou style.
Cyclone Blade!
Oh, he could've taken care of it.
I'm here in my bikini.
Um, I did that too.
It just took a couple hits before the one hit.
He was a monster?
Blame the blight.
I've seen it happen many a time.
That was more than one hit.
No!
People fall more easily to possession.
When you're possessed, you become a horse monster?
Thank you for helping us.
No thanks needed.
You'd already done most of the work.
Yeah, I did.
Thank you.
Actually, for recognizing that.
However, you must remain ever vigilant.
A moment's carelessness may cost you your life.
Right.
I am Muda-Sami.
I wander the land of Azuma on a quest to master the art of the sword.
They're making him so mysterious.
He's so...
Swordsman seeking greatness.
Wait, he's so cool!
Oh no, he's hot.
Put him in a sweat and suit.
You know it.
I have many questions for you.
Like, why are you in a bikini?
You must take this man to safety.
Oh!
Evil.
Mmm.
I come back and everybody's in bathing suits.
Now don't that just beat all.
Never thought a monster would target little ol' me.
Aw.
All that matters is that you made it home safely.
We're all indebted to our new chief in Muda-Sami.
You can say that again.
My thanks, y'all.
Y'all.
I will pay you a hundred fold.
Just say the word.
My thanks, y'all.
Mina-san.
Arigato.
Who's this fuzzball?
I am not a fuzzball!
For sure information, I am a divine descendant.
Well, aren't you a lovely young lady?
You a traveler?
Actually, I've dwelled in this village since time immemorial.
That's weird.
Come on now.
I've lived here all my life, and I've never seen a girl half as pretty as you.
I would remember that belly button.
Whatever.
Hello?
Not even half as pretty?
Okay.
Dang.
Now ain't that something.
A lot happened while I was gone, eh?
Hey.
Dramatic, dramatic bias.
You meant what you said earlier, right?
That you've never seen anyone half as pretty?
Uh, what did I say?
That you'd repay us a hundredfold?
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
You bet.
Only fair for saving my life.
You just say the word, and I'll come running.
That better apply to me, too.
Saving you was a team effort, okay?
Sorry, Suzu.
She's...
She's still growing.
Can't you humor me a little?
Not the inner dialogue.
My partner and I are gonna need your help later.
So, don't forget you owe us.
Chief, would you come with me a moment?
I'd like to give you something.
Oh, yeah?
Go on.
Take this.
Consider it a thank you gift.
What is it?
Isn't this...
Eggies?
Isn't this Eggie?
It was my trusty partner as a young man.
Ah.
I'm sure you'll make better use of it now.
Oh.
A bow.
Let's go.
Oh.
I got an achievement for defeating Mezuki, which was the horse.
Yeah.
A secondary weapon.
One you can switch to on the fly.
Let's say you're wielding a sword, then you suddenly feel like using a bow instead.
It's kinda like that.
Hmm.
Okay.
Alright.
Try it out yourself and you'll see.
Equip secondary weapon.
Oh, here.
Equipment.
Secondary weapon.
My bow.
Okay.
Yep.
Hey.
Put those skills to the test.
How do I...
Switch.
Hitting the target should be a piece of cake, right?
Oh.
Okay, Q.
Okay.
Alright.
Combo attack.
With the bow.
Use control to ready your bow.
Mouse to aim, then left click or V to fire.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh!
Is there...
Drop?
Oh, doesn't he like it?
Not bad.
Nice shot.
I see.
I was right to put my faith in you.
Thank you.
Are you absolutely sure?
I think it's time.
You see...
This recent incident with Takumi has forced me to seriously consider retirement.
Archer.
Oh.
I hate to ask for anything in return, but...
I'd like you to check the request board every so often.
Quest board.
The villagers will sometimes hang wooden emma plaques bearing their wishes.
Oh.
I'm sure they'd appreciate your aid.
Nice.
Um, I guess I'll consider a repayment for the bow.
Good.
Thank you for all of your help.
Well then, I'll leave this village in your capable hands.
Thanks, mister.
Go take a quick look at the request board.
It's your duty as both chief and earth dancer to help people out.
I don't even know what an earth dancer is quite exactly.
This...
This status has been thrown upon me.
Actually.
Ethan, happy birthday!
Minto yearns for the factories.
Villagers write down requests on wooden emma plaques and hang them on the request board.
Make their wish come true and they will reward you.
After you complete a quest, report back to the board to finish the job.
Finish the job.
Okay, hold on.
Wait!
Yes!
That kid is here!
Wow!
Hey there, fellow fanatic.
Did you find any other frog statues?
Okay, we'll reconsider our life decisions of telling this kid anything.
Yay!
Neat!
That sounds so cool!
Thanks!
You found five frog statues.
Here!
Oh!
What do we get?
Rice cracker recipe!
Nice!
Egg bowl recipe!
Come tell me when you found at least ten statues.
You can do it!
Okay!
Thank you!
Alright.
We must go to...
The shrine.
Up there.
Yummy.
Yeah, yummy.
Up here.
Okay, I was gonna say it better not be dirty.
Wait!
He...
He gets a little...
It's so cute!
So cute!
His shorts look a little tight.
You okay there, buddy?
Everybody...
Everybody is in swimsuits, you guys!
Equal opportunity.
He hasn't been here five minutes.
I don't think we've spoken even five words to the guy.
Ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Well, guys!
I think this might be a good place to end...
Ha ha ha!
I think.
Let's see what they're talking about.
Always a pleasure.
Ha ha ha!
Hi there!
Oh my god, everybody's yelling at me at once.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Spring Village is the second one.
What?
What just happened?
Nevermind.
My bond is strengthened.
Ciao!
Hello.
Hi.
Don't come up to me.
You freak me out a little bit.
Okay, let's talk to Itoha and then we'll end it.
Getting a feel for the village yet?
In case you forgot, my name's Itoha.
Oh, I've been here for six months!
It's kind of awkward introducing myself again.
Anyway, come visit Suzu and me at the tea shop whenever you like.
And bond up.
Hey.
Um... something else?
What is it?
Let's chat.
Well...
You hungry at all?
My shop has all sorts of yummy stuff on the menu.
What is it?
Bond up.
Good day.
Oh my gosh, they're all eating dongle.
They're so cute.
What are you eating?
Onigiri maybe?
The village is so lively!
Me and my bathing suit buddies.
Yay!
So guys...
Um... yeah!
This has been Rune Factory Guardians of Azuma!
Um... it's been a lot of fun playing.
And I hope you guys, uh... enjoyed it as well.
Um...
If you are interested in the game, again, it's on PC...
Oh...
Yes, Hina?
Like I'm not even there.
Um...
It's on...
PC, which I'm playing on as well...
As well as the Switch and the Switch 2!
But, um...
Yeah, thank you again to Marvelous for...
Uh...
Sponsoring me today!
And if you're interested in the game, I got a link in the...
Pinned message in chat!
And...
Link in the description!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
So...
I had a lot of fun!
Sorry I'm so sleepy!
Because I'm still jet lagged!
But hopefully in the next couple days, I'll be a-okay!
Thank you to our goal!
Thank you for the break!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you guys!
And...
Yeah!
Uh, maybe we'll play some more of it!
I am- I am having a lot of fun!
Um...
Especially for it being my first Rune Factory game, so...
I- I am curious, is this...
Similar?
Or different?
To how the other Rune Factory games...
Have been in the past?
If...
If you guys have...
Played before?
Hmm...
Pretty similar?
Combat is similar, but the village building is new.
Oh...
I see, I see, I see!
It's a bit different!
Hmm...
Why'd they...
They're all...
They all got up at once!
Oh...
Look at f...
They're like, streams over!
I guess it was lunch time, because look, it was 2 PM!
Maybe...
Stream's over!
Everybody get out!
Anyway, thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you!
Have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you guys when I see you...
NEXT!
I'll see you guys!
Bye-bye!
Allow me to reintroduce myself.
I am Ulalaka.
The joyful elegance of spring.
A pleasure to make your acquaintance.
What?
By the way...
Are you fond of music?
I would love to perform with an accomplished dancer such as yourself sometime.
Let's chat.
Yes!
We couldn't possibly restore this village without Takumi.
I hope he enjoys many years of good health.
Yes?
Don't talk about another man in front of me, and then increase our bond!
Is it your birthday?
Is that what you said, Karlamon?
Happy Birthday!
Glad I caught it before I left.
Okay!
Bye-bye!